[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
reporteros en france 24 si revelan con
gusto saludarlos desde que estalló la
lucha entre la fuerzas etíopes y el
frente de liberación del pueblo de tigre
decenas de miles de civiles han huido a
través de la frontera hacia el destino
sudan pero una vez a salvo en la
violencia en su tierra natal tienen que
sobrevivir a sus nuevas vidas en el
exilio para el primero de diciembre más
de 45 mil refugiados ya habían cruzado
la frontera entre etiopía y sudán en los
próximos meses y dependiendo de cómo se
desarrolle el conflicto naciones unidas
se estima que el número de refugiados
etíopes en ciudad aumentará hasta unos
200.000 al llegar no suelen tener nada
más que la ropa que visten algunos han
pasado hasta dos semanas caminando hacia
un lugar seguro y la mayor parte de ese
tiempo sin comida después de haber
evitado las aldeas ocupadas por milicias
o soldados todos cuentan sus historias
horribles de su ruta hacia el exilio
cadáveres en las calles ejecuciones
selectivas y además atentados con bombas
veamos el siguiente reportaje de bastian
[Música]
decenas de miles de personas han cruzado
este río huyendo de los combates entre
el ejército etíope y el frente de
liberación popular de tigre
[Música]
después de caminar por días para huir de
las milicias y los bombardeos este es el
último obstáculo en el camino hacia
sudán donde estarán a salvo
a bordo de este barco hay unas 50
personas
la mayoría de ellos solo lleva algunas
prendas consigo
[Música]
las milicias se apoderaron de nuestras
pertenencias cuando quisimos volver a
casa nos dispararon y mucha gente tuvo
que esconderse y vivir en la naturaleza
vargas italia nos morimos de hambre pero
oímos el rumor de que había un campo de
refugiados en sudán
[Música]
tras años de dirigir el país en el seno
de la coalición de gobierno
las autoridades de tigre se rebelaron
contra el poder del primer ministro
había momento al que acusan de marginar
a la población de la región
a los rebeldes y los realistas se les
acusa de atacar a los civiles causando
al menos cientos de muertes y
obligándolos a huir
estas dos familias dejaron su pueblo
juntas y caminaron durante casi quince
días
solo les quedan unos pocos kilómetros
más para convertirse oficialmente en
refugiados esperamos que aquí el
gobierno sea bueno y que haya paz todo
lo que sé es que arriesgamos nuestras
vidas y ahora queremos un gobierno
pacífico
el campamento de tránsito de jan diet ha
recibido a casi 30.000 personas desde el
comienzo del conflicto
[Música]
las dos familias se encuentran en un
espacio libre finalmente podrán
descansar y acostarse en el suelo la
gente que volvió a los pueblos nos
encontramos muertos en las calles
tenemos que enterrar los mismos
a enterrarlos
las casas fueron quemadas los milicianos
gritaban los tigres ya no deben morir
los tigres ya no deben irse así que
venimos aquí para estar a salvo
en tigre las redes de comunicación
fueron cortadas desde el comienzo del
conflicto el 4 de noviembre otro
refugiado les presta un teléfono es la
primera vez que pueden contactar a los
familiares que viven fuera de la región
o la muela
sí sí soy yo cómo estás cómo estás estoy
bien soy yo sé gay
estás a salvo ahora sí estoy bien están
matando a la gente ejecutando las
peticiones y nos el río hacia ciudad y
nuestra hermana sahai sabes dónde está
si está en danza no han tenido una
verdadera comida durante días es
imposible cocinar en el camino
el programa mundial de alimentos les da
raciones de lentejas y sorgo
hace 6 días que no comen nada aparte de
las semillas encontré
es bueno estar aquí
cae la noche en el campamento la
temperatura cae bruscamente aquí no
tienen un refugio ni mantas la aldea de
hand diet no puede alojar a todos estos
refugiados un vecino les ofrece café les
aconseja pedir ser transferidos a un
campo de refugiados permanente que se
supone está equipado para recibirlos y
me voy mañana quieren venir conmigo a un
vrac uva o prefieren quedarse aquí
bueno estoy pensando en establecerme en
este país estoy aquí con algunos de mis
hijos aunque otros se quedaron en
etiopía estoy feliz de estar en un lugar
seguro con ellos no creo que te vuelva a
ser nuestro país por todas las
atrocidades que han sucedido allí no voy
a mover los combates continúan
rodríguez le di con moto
[Música]
cerca de 40 buses llegaron durante la
noche para transportar a aquellos que
quieren ir al campamento
[Música]
las dos familias que acaban de llegar
tienen que esperar a ser registradas por
la onu antes de poder viajar
la joven que conocimos el día anterior
se está preparando para viajar con su
hermano
algo mayor aquí está metido ya trajeron
nuestras pistas en el base nos vamos
hacia una cuba hoy así que estamos
contentos
[Música]
pero aquí no
se les dan mascarillas para protegerlos
del polvo de las carreteras sudanesas
estos buses de otra época ya han
transportado a miles de refugiados todos
ellos han enfrentado la violencia de la
guerra
[Música]
la gente se moría las bombas venían de
la frontera con eritrea
destruían las casas y el centro de la
ciudad teníamos tanto miedo de morir que
escapamos
mi problema es que el ejército me decía
vuelve este es tu país tienes que servir
al ejército si no te dispararemos
es el ejército de abía ahmed y las
fuerzas de amaras y con mis propios ojos
cuerpos ardiendo porque eran ti gràcia
no
en un lugar llamado abadí shop las
fuerzas zanjadas los mataron con
cuchillos y machetes también iban a
matar a los tiranos en my cara ancianos
después de varias horas de espera
finalmente empiezan su travesía en su
regazo el eros sostiene su posesión más
preciada está estudiando ingeniería
estos son sus diplomas un elemento clave
que podría sacarla del campamento si el
conflicto continúa
estoy pensando en escribirles a algunas
universidades y pedirles una beca
estos son todos mis documentos los voy a
escanear y enviarlos por correo
electrónico
[Música]
les toma ocho horas de viaje llegar a
esta planicie desértica cientos de
refugiados son llevados a un rack o va
aquí los refugios son rudimentarios por
el momento viven uno encima del otro en
un calor sofocante
[Música]
a unos cientos de metros ayer su hermano
y su tío encontraron algo de sombra bajo
una torre de agua
[Música]
e
como 30 y de agua no había otros
refugiados les vendieron los
ingredientes para hacer giro un plato
tradicional etíope no nos dieron platos
para servir la comida tendremos que usar
el sartén
esperaban más ayuda de la onu y del
gobierno sudanés
ayer os decepcionadas pensó en irse del
campamento pero cambió de opinión a
washington de frei pensaba irme hoy pero
mi tío me pidió que me quedara cree que
nuestras condiciones de vida mejorarán
tal vez nos den un refugio no como ahora
así que va a intentar conseguir ayuda
pero en el campamento no encuentra a
nadie que le indique lo que tiene que
hacer
así que prueba suerte con el primer
grupo de gente que conoce
actual es el proceso para registrarse
que tengo que hacer tengo estos
documentos que no son los correctos
necesitas uno de estos y luego puedes
seguir el procedimiento pero no se
supone que ese título
luego va a la medialuna roja a buscar
una manta pero aquí tampoco tiene suerte
le dicen que vuelva otro día deprimida
ella eeuu sale en busca de señal para
hablar con un amigo que sigue en hand
diet y le aconseja que no suba el bus
así que creo que aquí funciona
no si me deja doble
no creo que te dejen volver a entrar
aquí como así vas a tener que usar todos
los medios posibles para salir de ese
campamento
y una vez que entras no puedes hablar
[Música]
el eros vuelve a su albergue improvisado
y se refugia en un libro
cuando huyó de su ciudad y del bombardeo
lo tomo por reflejo ella eeuu sabía que
en el campamento el tiempo sería largo
su familia ya estuvo en esta situación
antes
creo que fue hace unos 30 años mi mamá y
mi abuela estuvieron aquí justo donde
estamos ahora vinieron aquí debido a la
guerra entre lluvia y eritrea
el presidente eritreo isaias
estaban atacando la ciudad de húmera y
se asustaron y se recibieron aquí como
yo
[Música]
es imposible saber si alguna vez podrá
reanudar sus estudios o incluso volver a
ver a su madre de la que fue separada
durante los combates lleva siete días
refugiada en sudán y ya está desesperada
unos días después se va de nuevo en
busca de refugio y de nuevo es rechazada
ayer fui y me dijeron que volviera hoy a
las 10 pero hasta ahora no me han dado
nada así que estoy muy molesta el sol
está pegando fuerte y me hacen volver
una y otra vez y estoy muy enojada por
todo eso
en el camino de regreso se detiene
frente a las tiendas de campaña donde
acaban de llegar las nuevas familias ve
una cara familiar son las dos familias
que conoció en hand diet el día antes de
irse
[Música]
buenos días miren nuestra hermana viene
a vernos
buenos días
dame un abrazo como estas hermanas su
padre
ellos también esperaban tener un refugio
comida y agua en cantidades suficientes
pero no es el caso la alegría de ser
salvados de la guerra pronto se
desvaneció este lugar no está bien
dirigido los servicios son malos la
mitad de la gente obtiene algo y la otra
mitad no obtiene nada no siguen las
reglas
ayer os acompaña accede a pedir refugio
una vez más la joven se va con las manos
vacías ahora sólo tiene dos esperanzas
ser aceptada en una universidad en el
extranjero aunque la guerra termine y
poder volver a que obvian
[Música]
hasta aquí esta emisión de reporteros
recuerde que se le gustó el programa
puede verlo nuevamente a través de
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hacer una próxima oportunidad
[Música]